ici la chèvre et tendance la chèvre est
à l'honneur une reconnaissance bien
méritée pour l'ensemble du cheptel
caprin qui participent à la renommée
gastronomique et économique d'un
territoire dont sainte maure de touraine
et la capitale nous sommes au centre de
la production mondiale d'un petit bijou
de fromage le sainte maure de touraine
une aop depuis 1990 une appellation
d'origine protégée
une origine chargé d'histoire
[Musique]
d'après la légende tout commence en l'an
de grâce 732 venant du sud du royaume de
france les hordes de sarrasin déferle
sur les plaines du poitou avec pour
objectif de s'emparer du plus riche
symbole de la chrétienté d'alors
l'abbaye de saint martin de tours
ils affrontent l'armée franck de charles
martel aux marches de la touraine et
laissent leurs illusions de pillages sur
le champ de bataille et quelques rares
prisonniers parmi lesquels des femmes
qui transmettront leurs secrets de
l'élaboration du fromage à base de lait
de chèvre frais siècle plus tard la
tradition fromagère perdure sur ces
mêmes terres comme chez ce producteur
fermier et son cheptel de 120 chèvres
ici on respecte le cycle naturel des
animaux et jean-françois collecte le
lait de mars à septembre le matin on se
lave à 6h 6h15 tous les jours et après
on fait la passe bien on va dans les
champs tout je suis à fait on peut dire
que c'est spécifique quand même pas très
bon dans la tradition là haut et fort et
c'est dans précédent les
la volga op et bonfoh
je crois que pour avoir du bon lait faut
déjà commencer par l'alimentation
une bonne alimentation et après une
bonne alimentation une bonne production
de lait moi j'ai fait le choix de du
foin de l'illuminer du foin de fétuque
avant de donner de l'âme et rasent
c'était une aide prématurée lotis évitez
d'acheter de la pulpe de betterave mépor
dumont les faux pour essayer dans le
naturel comment vous le trouvez votre
image de moi je trouve doux voilà d'où
bas ou de bon voilà parce que c'est ce
que je donne à mes choix je pense qu'il
ya pour mal des leurs dans ce cas la
halle et la traite effectuer le
façonnage du sainte maure de touraine
peut commencer
c'est le travail de christine et l'on
produit 25 mille par an mélange celle du
soir avec celle du matin au bout des 48
heures on va apprendre le cahier
comparer partir dans les moules en forme
tronconique et ensuite ça va c'est
goûter pendant 24 ou des 24 heures on va
dérouler son fromage on va le thaï et on
va lui mettre une paille et ensuite salé
puis direction la loire ou température
et humidité de l'air sont contrôlés pour
un affinage qui respectent le cahier des
charges
onze jours donc pour élaborer ce fromage
de lait cru empressé avant de le
consommer dans les règles de l'art parmi
les 600 exploitations que compte la
filière caprine sur notre zone aop une
quarantaine seulement de petits
producteurs fermiers les autres livres
directement le relais à des centres de
production comme ici bienvenue à
l'électrique verneuil vous voyez ici les
camions qui viennent de décharger le
lait qui a été collecté ce matin et qui
va être transféré dans les temps que
vous voyez à ma gauche maintenant je
vous propose d'aller voir le stockage du
lait de chèvre eut acheté le plus gros
traitement de lait que nous faisons
c'est au niveau de la fromagerie ou
l'autre et entre 4 et 5 millions de
litres de lait de chèvre dont une grande
partie en crue entre autres pour la op
sainte maure de touraine le marché du
lait liquide en france est en régression
global
tous les confondues en revanche il
augmente énormément sur la partie lait
de chèvre puisque les deux petits
ruminants aujourd'hui ont la faveur des
consommateurs
nous avons toute une gamme de produits à
base de lait de chèvre collectés dans la
région clairement les produits phares ce
sont les aop et le plus bel aop fromage
de chèvre en france c'est le sainte
maure de touraine dont nous sommes un
des producteurs
voilà qui est typique avec sa forme
tronconique et ça paye à berneuil d'une
manière générale nous avons plusieurs
ateliers et en particulier l'atelier
fromage de chèvre est un atelier à
taille humaine donc forcément et nous
avons des méthodes traditionnelles comme
par exemple égouttage en 48 heures qui
fait partie du procès c'est qui est tout
à fait traditionnelle nous en sommes
fiers et je pense que les clients nous
disent aussi qu'ils en sont fiers
puisqu'ils viennent le goût déjà et puis
j'aime bien quand il est un petit peu
cei quand il est un peu frais il dans
les différents différentes maturation et
j'aime beaucoup ce fromage vous le
souhaitez comment un peu frais un peu
ferme sous peu à peu près alors la java
frais c'en est un peu crémeux et là ils
mettent un peu frêle qui reste souple 1
comme ceux ci à ce bien sec bien c'est
comme ça est-ce que c'est assez cela car
si notre but londres et se distingue par
son poids sa forme et sa couleur enchère
ou qui se décline également sous
différents affinage une variété de choix
apprécié des consommateurs et donc la
paille
elle ne sert souvent justement à faire
tout ce travail et maintenir le fromage
en une seule pièce
si je prends un extra c'est comme
aujourd'hui c'est là qu'on le voit à
quoi sert la paille ou et inserts
maintenir votre freinage pour enlever la
paille c'est simple regardez vous
appuyez dessus et vous tirez sur la
paille
et là vous contrôlez que la paille est
gravé et vous avez nom du fermier alors
particulière aussi la collerette fait
partie de l'appellation aussi pour moi
le sainte maure de touraine c'est
l'ambassadeur des fromages de la
touraine et quel ambassadeur
sainte maure de touraine appellation
d'origine protégée
un ambassadeur qui force même le plaisir
des palais étrangers pour preuve cette
collation improvisé autant que
chaleureuse avec quelques anglo-saxons
qui visiblement par notre fromage ça que
j'apprécie bien c'est cesser côté
crémeux c7 côté c'est très particulier
en fait cette texture qui est à la fois
crémeux mais qui est à la fois petites
touches ta mère ton amertume
moi j'aime bien le manger de temps en
temps le matin avec un peu de preuves
avec un peu de confiture framboise
s'inquiète pas très là les français ne
font pas en fait quand je quand je
demande ça dans dans un restaurant c'est
ces mêmes ces mêmes mal vu personne fait
la même
aussi toujours une expérience de voir le
goût qu'on va trouver ces sais plus
saleh au moins salée aux fermes au plus
éco sonnerait aux blancs et j'aime aussi
le fait que ce un goût un vrai goût en
good de la nature de la ferme de
vraiment de la chèvre que je pense qu'
aucun autre fromage à ce vrai goût comme
ça il ya des gens qui produisent aux
états unis man dans les fromages de
chèvre mais pas aussi bon que le formage
de sainte-maure oui j'ai été intronisé
dans le commanderie de chevalier de
sainte-maure ces deux grands media event
et des chèvres que je porte pour des
occasions important des mariages et tout
ça parce que c'est c'est ça rappelle de
ces comme la légion d'honneur pour moi
cette médaille qemu amber sur l'ensemble
géographique de production plus de 6
millions de fromage sont produits chaque
année dont 300 milles sont exportés hors
union européenne 7 millions de pas ils
sont également fabriqués par un esat
d'indre-et-loire un établissement et
service d'aidé par le travail
le sainte maure de touraine un savoir
faire et une réalité économique
le poids économique du simplement de
touraine aujourd'hui est estimée à 24
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
est-ce que c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
puisqu'on est la première appellation
qu'imprime de france et ça représente
1600 18 tonnes de fromages produits
commercialisés chaque année et on
regarde du département oui c'est un
chiffre conséquent on peut aussi
chiffrés effectivement les emplois
directs liés à ce produit qui sont
estimés aujourd'hui à 300 emplois et
viennent s'ajouter les emplois indirects
tels que le tourisme la restauration les
châteaux
qu'ils profitent également de la au
puissant clan de touraine consciente de
cette réalité économique la région
centre val de loire s'engage dans un
nouveau programme de financement sur
cinq ans pour soutenir la filière est sa
production et assurer sa pérennité
aujourd'hui on est sur un nombre
d'exploitations en constante diminution
et là l'enjeu sur les cinq années à
venir c'est d'arriver à transmettre les
exploitations est aussi installé des
jeunes et si paris vaut bien une messe
le sainte maure de touraine produits
d'exception mérite sa confrérie créée en
1972 à la sur la promotion de la
touraine en faisant connaître et
apprécier ses produits et plus
particulièrement ce délicieux fromage de
chèvre grand conseil se compose d'une
quarantaine de dignitaires qui profitent
de chaque occasion je cite pour diffuser
cette merveille de la gastronomie
tourangelle
c'est la première aop de france ça veut
déjà dire beaucoup
le sainte maure de touraine on a
forcément l'histoire également qu est
liée à la touraine
dans son hommage ceci dit après il
suffit d'y goûter
et quand on y goûte on tombe amoureux de
sainte maure de touraine forcement
le secondaire
ce jour nous sommes à loches un grand
chapitre se tient dans la cité royale en
compagnie d'autres confréries venues de
toute la france et même de l'étranger
j'ai trouvé ces fromages absolument
délicieux ça n'y a aucun problème et je
ne demanderai pas d'où ils viennent
parce que de toute façon tous les tous
les gens qui font du sainte maure de
touraine que ce soit des fermiers ou que
ce soit des laiteries nous avons nous
répondrons tous au même cahier des
charges et nous avons tous le même
souhait de diffuser au maximum ce
produit d'excellence une occasion
d'adouber de nouveaux chevaliers futur
ambassadeur avant de ripailler et bien
boire comme il se doit mais par
tradition
ne sommes nous pas en terre
rabelaisienne remarqué par balzac autres
figures littéraires tourangelle et fin
gourmet lui-même le sainte maure de
touraine se prêtent par ses
caractéristiques à bien des audaces
culinaire pour faire de la cuisine
certainement parce qu'on peut aller dans
plein de sens le sainte maure est bon à
tous les stades
donc il est il va être agréable entre un
fromage frais en demie a fini en fromage
très sec et il aura des utilisations
différentes
donc ça nous ouvre une gamme de cuisines
énorme par rapport à tous ces stades qui
sont tous agressant ce qui n'est pas
forcément le cas de certains d'autres
fromages
ce sera d aider des cinq meurtres est
très sec qu'on aura laissé passer d'une
année à l'autre et qu'on pourra utiliser
râpé comme condiment dans des salades ou
dans les pattes
ce sera du fromage frais que l'on pourra
maintenant une salade parce que ce sera
plutôt l'été où on a besoin de fraîcheur
et commettra des salades en petits dés
avec avec des tomates un peu comme
pouvons utiliser de la feta et puis et
puis ce sera là le fromage des mécènes
comme ballack il vraiment le clip est
née l'idée du 5 morts et où là on va
pouvoir faire des cuissons à marquer ce
que vous nous avez préparé comme petite
recette à base de sainte maure de
touraine est bien la sienne recettes de
tonnes donc c'est une petite charlotte
d'automne aux cinq ports de touraine et
au cresson puisque c'est aussi le début
du cresson à 7 donc du rhume en légumes
utilisés de la sucrine du berry de là
courge de nice longue et
dur à dire hey mythe c'est un très joli
radis inquiets rouge dedans je crée sont
bien sûr et puis le 5 morts voilà 200
corps est déjà un que l'infini moelleuse
raffiné cette bûche de lait cru
traversée d'une paille de seigle a su
depuis l'époque carolingienne conservé
toute son authenticité
une production de proximité grâce aux
ressources locales humaine et animale
qui cultive ce jardin de la france il
est fabriqué ici et nulle part ailleurs